zwölf stunden flug sind es von zürich
nach singapur eine wertvolle zeit für
seilbahn direktor bernhard scheinen sich
vorzubereiten auf den kampf um die
asiatischen touristen
ja sicher kommen
sie ist witzig das kommt zu besuchen
sein werk ist das gipfel massiv zwischen
dem waadtländischen les diablerets staat
das gebiet direkt den marketing namen
glacier 3000 ursprünglich war es vor
allem als gletscherskigebiet bekannt
doch skifahrer sind hier inzwischen in
der minderheit
es dominieren die fußgänger vor allem
aus asien
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
viele der gäste haben hier ihr erstes
erlebnis mit schnee und eis geboten mit
ihnen eine unterhaltungs infrastruktur
die kritiker als alpen disneyland
bezeichnen
[Musik]
sie kostet 1500 schweizer franken
wie viel es braucht um die asiaten auf
den schweizer berg zu bringen davon
handelt diese filme singapur
der stadtstaat mit knapp sechs millionen
einwohnern nach ecuador tropisch folgt
das klima temperaturen um die 30 grad
für bernhard tschannen ein heißes
pflaster
wie läuft ein bisschen ist nämlich
schlechter als in anderen asiatischen
staaten
das soll sich jetzt ändern
das shoppingcenter monat spezialisiert
ist auf europareise und die lustige wies
alle benannt
asien gilt nach wie vor als markt mit
riesigem touristen potenzial aber auch
die konkurrenz schläft nicht
kaum ein flecken der welt der hier nicht
angeboten wird
auch schweizer berge haben sich hier
fest etabliert insbesondere jungfrauen
titel ist ja das unternehmen vor allem
sechszylinder sally bercow ziel ist eine
das ist gut die place jungfrau das ja
schon ausflugsziel
aber ich lasse die geschosse und das
wäre ich hoffe und das level ob porsche
und dem minister nicht alle zu scotts
ziel ist dass sie möglichst zweiteiligen
update region von schweiz abdecken und
der stoff schon gut kennen versucht die
asiatischen touristenströme umzulenken
von der achse mailand luzern titel ist
in richtung genferseegebiet so
schneeweiß hier
okay wir haben direkt wenn sie von
mailand kommen nehmen sie der autobahn
nach martigny dann gehen wir auf den
glacier 3000 die ganze reise dauert fünf
stunden mit pipi stoppt dann um 1 uhr
mittagessen auf dem berggipfel
übernachtungen motte am nächsten tag
können wir eine schiffstour auf dem
genfer see machen mit einem besuch des
olympischen museums in lausanne und dem
schloss dann noch eine übernachtung
danach shopping und weiter nach paris
die skandinavier waren offensichtlich
auch schon hier
sie stehen hoch im kurs
bisher waren die populären destinationen
natürlich im zentralen westeuropa
schweiz paris deutschland oder holland
aber heute suchen unsere kunden oft
exotischere ziele island steht ganz hoch
im kurs oder finnland
die gäste wollen die nordlichter sehen
die aurora da hat eine richtige jagd
darauf eingesetzt
das ist eine neue art von jagd es ist
tatsächlich sehr schön ich habe schon
gesehen ja wunderbar die grün violetten
farben
diese firma bringt jährlich rund 3000
gäste in die schweiz
bald soll auch le diable ring programm
sein hier ist der usb stick mit den
neuen fotos ich würde empfehlen dass sie
unsere hängebrücke als highlight fängt
du ins programm nehmen also besonders
minister spezialisiert auf die
gruppennamen aktivitäten zusätzlich gold
tonne und du darfst über nicht
spezialisieren und ich habe das klima
plus von qualität von produkt was uns
macht und zusätzlich ist einfach nicht
bis sie
die reisebüros sind nicht immer leicht
zu finden und das bei dieser hitze
immer wieder eine herausforderung für
den berner oberländer
sorry canucks
der austragungsmodus
das war
okay okay aber redet mit street view
stößt das ist jetzt eine der größten
meister agierte also für incentive
gruppen
das heißt das dass sie geschäftsgruppen
konferenzen reagierte und da jetzt ganz
europa 43 liegt dem zeugnis im sommer wo
für klassik und und wo er die nacht in
lausanne mit dem body was wollen sie
vielleicht etwas wasser und ja gerne was
wären sie nicht krank ist und daher
immer das lieblich und pc und nach
himmel strategisch die sitzplatz
aussuchen das direkt im werk und
besetzen was machen sie das ist der
highlights während seiten gut also ist
er viel mit den highlights sehr kurz
sagt die ganze reise startet mit dem
glacier 3000 und fährt mit der großen
seilbahn hoch dann auf die hängebrücke
pitwalk sie laufen wirklich durch den
himmel
sie können den morgen sehen das
matterhorn die jungfrau es gibt viele
aktivitäten im schnee
in das know how das restaurant botta
design von mario botta sind berge und
schnee allein nicht genug es braucht
aktivitäten unterhaltung
man muss die besucher beschäftigen
unsere kunden genießen ansonsten würden
sie höchstens schnell einen schneemann
bauen und das war's dann
man muss sie unterhalten ich denke das
angebot da ist gut aber der hauptgrund
sollten dennoch die berge schnee und die
schweiz seien aber es braucht ein paar
extras ein paar abenteuer dinge die man
in singapur nicht machen geklagt
mittagszeit in singapur
irgendwie scheinen die fleißigen asiaten
aber nicht so recht ruhe zu kommen
einen business lunch gibt es auch für
bernhard chairman bestellt wird hier
übrigens auf dem tablett
das projekt
bernhard tschannen 4 bringt jährlich
rund zwei bis drei monate in asien
inzwischen etwas weniger weil er
kürzlich vater einer tochter geworden
ist täglich hat er bis zu einem dutzend
meetings
für fußmassagen hatte keine zeit
mag sein das ist haben wir die rechte
chrome
wenn wir probieren probieren dezent drei
sekunden aber die machen das gut das
nächste meeting in der hintersten ecke
der reiseagentur auch hier dominiert
schon die jungfrau region
doch es scheint ein erfolgserlebnis zu
geben wir haben wir den glacier 3000 als
ausflugsziel kommt klasse 3000 aber
nicht vor
bieten sie überhaupt eine rundreise an
in der sie den glacier 3000 besucher
nein nein okay kann ich die broschüre
mitnehmen
es ist nicht ganz klar
auf die asiatischen touristen zu setzen
ist eine idee die diablo aus der not
geboren wurde
2005 machte das gletscherskigebiet
konkurs gut betuchte geschäftsleute aus
gstaad kauften die firma auf unter ihnen
ex formel 1 chef bernie ecclestone
das schweizer fernsehen berichtete
darüber die große grund laut vergibt
fußi ages bald genauso wie die
spektakuläre bergstation oder personen
stararchitekt mario botta verteilt
gestaltet ich versuche das
wintersportgebiet zum erfolg zu bringen
sie besitzt aber jetzt richtet man
einmal mit ganz großes kino wie jetzt
wenn man links marcel bach immobilie aus
gstaad mit der formel 1 chef bernie
ecclestone es weitere winter landtag die
marcel bach wird aber ganze nation werde
wie jungfraujoch oder lediglich um die
großen einzuholen ließen die neuen
investoren unter anderem eine lange
rodelbahn bauen die höchste der welt
sagt man hier auch in den ausbau des
skigebietes investierten sie insgesamt
investitionen von über 30 millionen
franken an weihnachten trafen wir grüne
ecclestone im staat wieder begleitet von
seiner brasilianischen ehefrau fabiana
und von immobilie marcel bach
die zwischen acht und 80 jährige
ecclestone ist zufrieden dass das
gletscherskigebiet erhalten blieb auch
dank der asiatischen fußgänger
ich finde es ist super sonnen hat ganze
arbeit geleistet
er macht das klettergebiet weltweit
bekannter es ist mir in den letzten
tagen aufgefallen dass viele inder hier
in den ferien sind ja heute hatten wir
zb 15 gruppen oben aus indonesien
thailand singapur china und anderen
ländern erster linie führt regierung
macht und nicht als investment gewaltig
sind wir froh wenn wir über leitung von
investieren und erhält funktioniert die
anzahl asiatische gäste hat um das 15
fache zugenommen aber man ist noch weit
entfernt vom titlis und jungfrau darum
kämpfen weiter um jeden gast
heute begleitet er deine group aus
singapur ein herzliches willkommen euch
allen
wir gehen zuerst in den dritten stock da
gibt es toiletten
dann gehen wir zur hängebrücke co keine
angst sicher meine mutter hat höhenangst
ging aber dennoch drüber ihr schafft das
schon
von hier aus kommt ihr durch das uhren-
und souvenirgeschäft dann runter zum
gletscher dort gibt es den schnee
funpark und hundeschlitten mit den
huskies
dann kommt die zurück und es gibt es
mittagessen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
sie sehen hier den nobler das motto und
die jungfrau also alle drei bekannten
gipfel europas sind von hier aus
sichtbar
heute sind sie aber der nebel
[Musik]
so etwas gehört die drück ab das
eigentlich zu sagen oder koffer mit dort
miteinander verbinden wir hatten einige
nach stimmt natürlich ausflugszielen ab
sondern natürliche schönheit durch die
aktivität um das ganze aufgepeppt wird
auch mit einem pistenfahrzeug bus und
mit kurzen hundeschlittentouren letztere
kosten stolze 30 franken pro person im
funpark ein schneemann mit ein paar
schritten amüsiert sich die familie aus
singapur
sie alle sind das erste mal in europa
[Applaus]
[Gelächter]
in singapur ist es ja das ganze jahr
über sehr heiß warum gerade hier
wir machen hier ferien meine jungs
wollten etwas in diesem stil erleben das
können wir daher nicht
wir hatten gehört dass sie eine
rodelbahn gibt aber leider ist die
offenbar winter zu ja eigentlich wollten
wir die rodelbahn erleben
das ist ein bisschen enttäuschend nun
wir können ja nicht ski fahren aber ich
denke diese schlitten gegenüber um etwas
spaß zu haben
da ist
nach dem spiel das mittagessen
trockenfleisch frühstück käse
[Musik]
und dann shopping ohne das geht bei den
asiaten gar nichts sagen die touristiker
[Musik]
familie genießt die schweizer folklore
und beiden hauptschulen bespricht mit
dem chef des singapurischen
reiseveranstalters gemeinsame
zukunftsperspektiven
ein paar wochen später und mit ganz
anderem essen auf den tisch geht diese
diskussion in singapur weiter
der persönliche kontakt sei das a und o
im asiatischen geschäft
ja
das wird dann auch schon mal bei einem
bier in singapur entschieden
[Musik]
es ist ein harter kampf um die
asiatischen touristen für manche
schweizer bergbahnen sind die asiaten
die größten hoffnungsträger
darum werden sie oft auch mit niedrigen
preisen angelockt chairman spricht von
preisdumping muss man leider sagen dass
priester bergbahnen sörenberg zum ein
viertel vom schweizer preise sogar ein
fünftel unter natürlich große konkurrenz
begrüßen
klingt bedrängnis statt einfach als
aussteller multimedia oder hannes die
schmerzgrenze und auch eine tonlage
wenn jetzt business verlieren oder
halbjährlich einfach viel langsamer
gewachsen als auf einen rest von
singapur weiter nach thailand und
indonesien
wir machen einen besuch in einem
aussenquartier vom singapur
hier wohnt familie co sie sind seit ein
paar wochen zurück von ihrer europareise
und formidable der massiv mein vater mit
seinem schneemann
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
ja
diese musik gefiel mir jede schweiz
bilanz mit etwas distanz sehr schön nett
der menschen aber auch ziemlich teuer
und da noch eine etwas überraschende
kritik wir in singapur sind ja streng
mit der sauberkeit
wir versuchen nicht einfach wegzuwerfen
zb das papier von kaugummis oder
süßigkeiten
werfen wir in den abfall und es gibt
dafür überall eimer in der schweiz war
das schwieriger da mussten wir manchmal
die abfälle in unsere taschen stecken
und auf paletten waren schwierig zu
finden mit der februar-zahlen ist wieder
zurück aus asien nach dem schwierigen
beginn in singapur seit die
verkaufspreise in thailand und
indonesien erfolgreich verlaufen
indonesien kommt gut und thailand und
sogar so gut dass im gesetz würde der
große schritte gemacht die letzten zwei
jahre und das hat eigentlich das großes
wachstum von 20 bis 25 prozent neue
scania aus wer wird speziell in thailand
ist von ingo verstorben ist ja klafft in
lausanne
und das natürlich aber wieder eine
schöne geschichte machen mit losen oder
könig geklappt dass wir 10 uhr mit dem
klassik musik mit anderen produkten
passen
das konzert am markt
geschichten schnee und spiele für die
asiaten
die skifahrer sind inzwischen auf dem
zweiten rang
so sieht der wintertourismus in zukunft
aus zumindest hier zwischen le diable
und staat
[Musik]